Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
I am sure that every one of us have overheard
conversations at a workplace where people
talked about taking the stairs instead of
the elevator, and, as a result, getting leaner.
There was also a running joke on the internet
about Arnold Classic, a famous bodybuilding
competition/festival, where I think it's fair
to say that people tended to favor the escalator
instead of the stairs. So, this is it, we're
going to settle this here and now. Do we get
lean from taking the stairs every day?
Scientists set up a controlled experiment
where over a hundred subjects climbed 11 stories
of staircases, ascending a total of 27 meters
vertically. Their oxygen consumption and heart
rate was measured, and most importantly for
us, the amount of caloric cost of this undertaking.
They have found that all this self flagellation
with ascending 11 stories of staircases burns
a whopping 19.7 kilo calories. Each step is
worth approximately one tenth of a kilo calorie
if we're ascending. Descending is worth approximately
half of that. Apparently, these bodybuilders
know what they are doing.
The authors diplomatically noted:
Stair-climbing exercise using a local public-access
staircase met the minimum requirements for
cardiorespiratory benefits and can therefore
be considered a viable exercise for most people
and suitable for promotion of physical activity.
Which sounds like the scientific equivalent
of "well, better than nothing".
So does this mean that you shouldn't take
the stairs at work? If you're looking to get
lean because of that, no, not a chance. However,
if you are looking for a refreshing cardiovascular
exercise in the morning that refreshes your
body, and makes you happier, start climbing.
I do it all the time and I love it!
So, we are exploring so far uncharted territories
and this makes the first episode on nutrition
(should have said exercise, sorry!) in the
series, if you would like to hear more of
this, let me know in the comments section.
I'd also be happy to see your paper recommendations
in nutrition as well.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!